"Even if you've fallen once,"
"wager your life,"
"bring back your master at all costs."
"That is what it means to be my shinobi."
That was our little Lord, our young prince, speaking invoking our Shinobi's code of honor and
Imploring us to find him and bring him back safely.
But perhaps even more striking than our Lord's voice is our own.
The Undead Slayer
"Sure, I will take it."
In my last video, we talked about the red sheathed second blade on Sekido's back,
something that was touted as an unlockable weapon for later in the game.
And this is it. The Undead Slayer
It's almost certainly a special type of blade that's for killing immortal beings
and we'll talk about it a little bit later.
At the end of the video, we hear our young Lord speak once again,
and this time is talking in a sort of formal, entreating tone.
"Wolf."
"Along with my blood, you must live."
So we already know that our Prince is special because of his blood.
That's why the Ashina clan stole him from us in the first place.
And when he says "Live along with my blood" he could simply be imploring us to sort of fight for both of their lives.
But he could also mean it in a supernatural sense.
It could literally be the blood that's keeping us alive.
And From Software could be hinting at something supernatural again
That's our two lives are very intertwined.
There are three other characters voiced in the trailer.
The first is the woman with the red umbrella. She said,
"I have witnessed"
"Syura once before."
Syura might have a bit of a double meaning. The more conventional interpretation is
that she has witnessed a scene of great carnage once before. For example,
this could be referenced to the burning village in the intro.
She could be talking about all the terrible devastation that usually follows war.
Alternatively though, Asyura is also a type of wicked demigod in Buddhist mythology.
Sort of a type of anti-God or demon that's often depicted get this as having six arms.
Sound familiar? I reckon it's likely that we've signed a bit of a deal with the devil here.
But moving on,
"It's been a while"
"Brat of the Owl."
This is a curious statement.
The words"it's been a while"
suggests that our character has a history with this woman or at least that we've met her before.
She calls us a brat. She's rude, but who or what is the Owl?
It could be our clan. It could be our Lord. It could be our God.
Nobody knows, but she's not the only one who speaks mockingly to our shinobi.
We also have this guy,
"Am I getting in your way?"
"Shinobi of the heir."
This could also be interpreted as "You would block my path, Shinobi of the heir."
And this character is insane in the trailer.
But, can I just say both this man and our shinobi have voice actors that sound
so so similar to the voice actors of Guts from Berserk. And if you've watched Berserk,
which you really should, you'll understand how bloody fitting this is.
Anyway, those were just the translations.
Now let's dig into the weapons, the bosses, and the environments.
We open on the burning village scene, which is something that we've seen a few times now
so it must be a pretty important story event.
Our shinobi lies beaten on the floor and
our little Lord talks about how death should not stop us from rescuing him
Then we're up on our feet and we're sprinting past a flag featuring a pretty complex Kanji that
likely references a Kudaokami, which is a sort of dragon God
residing in the mountains or
mysterious rain dragon?
This valley serpent that we saw in the E3 trailer does fit the bill,
but with the translations I'm told, we shouldn't jump to conclusions because
we're missing a ton of context and our translations could be a little bit inaccurate as a result.
In the next scene,
we stealth over some enemies who are sitting and poring over a map
and it's definitely worth noting that Sekiro so far
has made a big effort to make sure that their enemies are actually
acting like they belong in their environments. They're not just standing around most of the time.
And then there's this. Wall jumping.
So you could not do this in the Gamescom demo.
So it must be one of those unlockable skills that Sekiro can develop. Added to the list.
And, remember if we can endlessly jump between walls like this,
then that should also mean that we're able to endlessly bounce on top of enemies as well.
Three monks walk through a tranquil sun-drenched forest,
which is a sort of warm setting that we haven't actually explored before in a From Software game.
Now you can still see the sunlight filtering through as we head inside actually.
And here, Sekiro is showing off how bloody fast is possible to block attacks in this game.
He gets perfect blocks on every one of these by tapping the L1 button. He isn't just holding it down.
This is a trick wall, which functionally will be replacing illusory walls.
Except I'm sure they're used for stealth as well
This is followed by the woman with the red umbrella who actually peers over the cliff here.
This gave me a bit of Patches PTSD, but that I remembered.
"Wait, we don't have fall damage in Sekiro."
"What is Patches gonna do. He's gonna have to up his game."
And then we have Fushikiri. Undead Slayer.
I'm sure most of you have played The Witcher series.
So I bet this second blade reminds you of the second silver blade that Geralt wields in that game.
In The Witcher, Geralt has a second silver blade that is way more effective against monster-type enemies
and it seems like this Undead Slayer weapon will be better against
unnatural maybe immortal creatures in Sekiro
and perhaps it'll be able to unlock special moves as well.
There was actually a consumable item in the demo that I didn't talk about much.
It was called Divine Confetti.
And if you used it, you spread it around yourself and it dispelled darkness.
But the description says that it assists in fights against ghost type enemies and
clearly a big thing in Sekiro is going to be stealthing around and discovering the weak points of your enemies and
Divine Confetti that lets you hit ghost type enemies and a second sword that allows you to hit mortal enemies is
perfectly aligned with that sort of philosophy.
And now since we've gone from one weapon to two weapons, why not three?
At first glance that looks like we're wielding a spear instead of a sword,
but it's actually not a main hand weapon
it's a prosthetic weapon that sort of starts off as this tiny blade on your wrist.
But then the shaft extends, mid attack to a ridiculous length that pins a far away enemy.
It pulls them up close to us and then Sekira performs an art that is called Iaido [居合道]
which is sort of a smooth controlled attack where you're able to pull your sword out of its scabbard
and attack in one smooth motion.
The attack itself has a sort of milky white streak to it,
and I don't really know what to make of that.
But this guy crawling away on all fours, he wants none of it.
Next, the Japanese symbol for smoke and then:
In the Gamescom demo, there was an item called "Fistful of Ash"
which you could chuck at an enemy and it would basically have the same function as this red cloud.
It allows you to re-enter stealth and it allows you to make your escape.
And you should make no mistake this sort of execution attack
could be an entire new category of unlockable skills.
I bet it's not just limited to this one. Imagine how many other types of unlockable execution skills there can be.
And then we have this incredible cinematic scene where an old woman boss
dashes confidently on threads as thin as spiders silk.
You can see them flashing here.
It's worth noting that this actually takes place in the temple that we've seen a few times now.
And this was a place that we speculated might actually be the hub world of Sekiro.
And is anyone going to talk about how fast these enemies are attacking?
Timing your blocks to some of these attacks is gonna be like playing osu! on max difficulty.
It's pretty much a rhythm game at this point
And then we have the corrupted monk which shows itself so I can finally talk about it.
This was the Gamescom boss that we weren't allowed to show you guys and
Man, this was such a good fight.
You only see a couple of elements of the fight here, unfortunately.
We see this gray mist illusion phase that you can actually
sort of avoid by swinging between the branches and just waiting it out.
Here you see Sekiro doing an execution and
taking off one of the three health bars that the monk has.
But what you don't see is the entire rhythm of this fight.
The boss actually has a attack pattern that's really similar to the Dancer in Dark Souls 3.
It's sort of relentless and flowing and it takes a really long time to wear down her posture
to the point where you can actually do an execution like this.
Honestly, I think since you can die so many times in Sekiro,
they've balanced that out by making the boss fights really, really long.
I wouldn't be surprised if most boss fights will long like this one is.
To finish, a white ape with a big old blade stuck through its neck
throws us to the ground and the trailer ends.
I can't wait.
t before I go, I have to give special thanks to all of the translators
who have offered their help to the community in translating.
Your skills are going to be in really high demand as we explore Sekiro.
Special thanks to patrons as always.
Thanks for watching and I'll see you next time.